[Music]
hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
it's that time of the month again Sony
have revealed the sick know the eight
free games yes you heard me right the
eight free titles will be getting as PS
Plus subscribers this month we have an
adventure title a fantasy outing a psvr
launch title a destruction filled racing
title and a game about a pigeon school
yep I am serious
like always one PS Vita game will be
playable on the ps4 and all eight of
these games can be downloaded from
Tuesday the 5th of September let's start
with those offerings on the ps4 and
kicking off the month is infamous second
son this is the third installment of the
infamous series but we've already had a
taste of it on PS Plus through the
standalone DLC first light we received
back in January 2015 if this is new to
you then let me outline the basics
Delsin Rowe is a conduit which basically
means he's a superhuman who can harness
powers such as smoke neon and even
concrete
you'll be Park whoring your way through
Seattle beating the heck out of the DUP
indestructible areas with extremely
satisfying combat elements depending on
your playstyle
you'll either be the hero of the city
needs of a villain the authorities paint
you to be utilizing the morality system
you'll likely play this game twice to
see both the good and bad endings to the
game the reviews are quite varied with
the average coming out at about 8 out of
10 this may have aged since its release
in 2014 but it's still worth your time
the neon effects alone are a wonder to
experienced in North America you'll
receive strike vector ax this one's a
multiplayer third and first person air
combat title trying its best to bring
back the brilliance of crimson skies
this one is all about reflexes in fast
paced action across the solar system
strike vector ax currently yields a
review score of 75 out of 100 here in
Europe the next offering on ps4 is child
of light a side-scrolling platformer
steeped in RPG elements this one
attained numerous 9 out of 10 reviews
Joo
to the simultaneous simplicity and
hidden depth the art style makes the
game feel like a living watercolor
painting but it's the combat system
which defines its brilliance it's like
playing a forward-thinking fairy tale
and hey she's got a big-ass sword so you
don't have to be put off by the
childlike charm child of light is filled
with skill trees inventory options and a
majestic blend of real-time and
turn-based combat the bonus title that's
you continues to appear on PS Plus what
I've told you about that last month and
the month before so I'll leave that one
there another piece of additional
content which I have to shout about
comes in the shape of rigs mechanized
combat league which is for all as psvr
users yeah this is the first virtual
reality game on PlayStation Plus this
one puts you in a cockpit of a Titan in
a futuristic sports tournament not for
the faint-hearted some models will have
trouble with motion sickness here but
let's celebrate the fact that Sony are
finally supporting virtual reality on PS
Plus over to the ps3 and our first
offering is truck racer in which you
race five tons of metal over 48 tracks
with highly destructible vehicles if
you've ever played Destruction Derby on
the ps1 you'll feel the nostalgia hits
you right away
this title supports split-screen play
and of course online carnage too game
number 6 for the month is handball 2016
a sports title which I do not know
anything about quickly looking up the
rules of handball I can tell you with
confidence the objective of the game is
to throw a ball into a net why don't we
just pretend it's FIFA but with hands
instead of feet sorry I can't help much
here
Metacritic has this worn out two point
four out of five finally the offerings
on the under loved Vita the first title
we are doomed is also available on the
ps4 this one is a twin stick shooter
which works so well on the Vita it may
resemble the 90s rave but once your eyes
adjust there's a little more to it I
found the endless mode quite addictive
with constant enemies drawing close you
can easily play for 90 minutes without
realizing we are doomed has a Metacritic
score of 61% finally game number 8 for
the month is hate uphold boyfriends hats
a full boyfriend I'm not sure
on how to pronounce that one this is one
of the most bizarre video games I have
ever seen as you are accepted as the
only human in a school of pigeons I'm
going to read word for word the
description roam the halls and find love
in between classes as a student at the
world's greatest pigeon High School in
the delightful hater full boyfriend make
of that what you will personally I'll be
running a mile so there we have the
eight games to get our teeth into over
September 2017 I'm really looking
forward to jumping back into infamous
again and finally giving child of light
the time it really deserves for me the
highlight of the month is Riggs as PS
plus is finally rewarding psvr users but
my opinion doesn't matter what are you
downloading and what do you think of
September's offerings please let me know
your thoughts in the comments below I'm
Adam from PlayStation granade I'll see
you next time
[Music]